Nous pouvons lire à nouveau les premiers paragraphes du chapitre 8,
« Les Christs, les médiateurs ».
Et les premiers paragraphes de la confession de foi
nous disent les suivants.
« Il a plu à Dieu, dont son dessein éternel,
de choisir et d'ordonner le Seigneur Jésus,
son Fils unique, selon l'alliance passée entre deux,
pour être les médiateurs entre Dieu et l'homme. »
Donc c'est un petit rappel que nous faisons
par rapport à quel point dans cette série d'études
basées sur notre confession de foi,
nous étudions à propos du Christ.
Donc on sait tellement bien que le Christ est au centre des Écritures,
il permet toutes les Écritures,
et on pourrait se demander pourquoi on n'a pas commencé par là.
Et donc on a connu déjà toutes ces raisons.
Et nous étudions à propos du Christ
quand on considère la doctrine de la rédemption,
car pour bien comprendre les besoins du Christ
pour qu'il vienne en tant que Dieu incarné,
Fils des Dieux incarnés,
on a dû créer quelques catégories de compréhension
dans cette didatique des Dieux
qui, comme dans une école élémentaire,
nous préparait pour comprendre les besoins du Christ,
les bénéfices du Christ,
les caractéristiques particulières du Christ.
Mais par exemple, la personne du Seigneur Jésus,
on a déjà étudié quand on a étudié
la doctrine de la Trinité,
la doctrine sur Dieu.
Car cette personne qui a pris la forme humaine,
qui a pris la nature humaine,
c'est donc la deuxième personne de la Sainte Trinité.
Et donc, dans ces premiers paragraphes,
il a plu à Dieu,
dans son descent éternel,
de choisir et ordonner le Seigneur Jésus,
son fils unique,
selon l'alliance passée entre eux deux,
pour être les médiateurs entre Dieu et l'homme.
Cette première phrase,
c'est un rappel de plusieurs choses
qu'on a déjà considérées pour arriver ici.
On a déjà considéré la nature des Dieux,
on a déjà considéré les descendants éternels des Dieux
qui a Christ au centre,
et en même temps,
d'avoir pointé ou choisi Christ
et de l'ordonner pour être les médiateurs
entre Dieu et l'homme,
selon cette alliance passée.
Donc cette alliance est une alliance éternelle,
avant même la création du monde,
Dieu le Père, Dieu le Fils,
Dieu le Saint-Esprit,
considère les plans et les desseins éternels
qui comprend la création parfaite de l'homme,
et l'homme en faisant usage de sa liberté,
de sa libre agence,
et dans les cas exclusifs,
avant la chute d'Adam et Ève,
de leur libre arbitre,
chose qui a été perdue après la chute,
et donc,
avec un dessein parfait de la part de Dieu
qui inclut
la liberté
de l'être humain
qui se rébelle contre Dieu
et qui passe
à avoir besoin
d'une rédemption.
Et Dieu,
dans ses pleines lignes des grâces,
d'alliances,
avait déjà,
selon son dessein éternel
et selon ses conseils divins trinitaires,
établit les seigneurs,
Jésus,
Dieu le Fils comme médiateurs.
Et donc,
quand on arrive à ce point,
on a déjà considéré
toute la didatique biblique,
en fait,
que Dieu établit une relation
avec les êtres humains
sur les cadres
ou sur la base d'une alliance,
et une alliance à chaque fois
en médiateur.
Et Christ,
elle est médiateur
qui a été typifiée
par tous les autres
et les seuls vrais médiateurs
qualifiés comme il faut
pour être un vrai médiateur
entre Dieu
et l'homme,
nature divine,
nature humaine,
etc.
Et toute la didatique biblique
de cette médiation
va impliquer
que notre représentant
désormais
soit un représentant
qui soit parfait
là où Adam a échoué,
un représentant sans péché,
et qui doivent accomplir
parfaitement la loi,
chose qu'aucun être humain
ne peut plus les faire.
Et donc,
il faut que ces médiateurs
ne viennent pas
de la lignée d'Adam
et voilà pourquoi,
comme on verra,
la promesse a été faite
en évoquant la descendance
ou la sémence
de la femme
et pas celle
de l'homme,
car le nouvel Adam
viendra
à travers une mère,
mais
sa nature humaine
n'aura pas
des pères.
Et donc,
cette lignée,
c'est une lignée
divine
pour introduire
un nouvel Adam
mais qui doit aussi
avoir la nature humaine
pour pouvoir nous représenter,
qui doit être née
d'une femme
et être née
sous la loi
pour accomplir
la loi parfaite
à notre place.
Donc,
c'est de cette manière
que les Christ,
les médiateurs
nous ont introduit
en faisant
une connexion
vers l'arrière
avec plusieurs doctrines
qu'on a déjà étudiées
et
nous avons aussi
considéré
la grandeur
du Saint-Jésus
comme l'une
des motivations
principales
pour étudier
cette doctrine générale
qui va traiter
du Christ
les médiateurs.
Donc,
l'importance
d'étudier
les sujets
est une importance
évidente
par rapport
à l'histoire
elle-même.
Donc,
même si on n'est pas
encore en train
de traiter
la parole
des dieux,
on sait très bien
qu'il s'agit
de la personnalité
la plus importante
de toute l'histoire,
l'histoire
de l'humanité
divisée entre
avant Christ
et après Christ
et particulièrement
pour les christianismes
quand on compare
les religions,
presque toutes les religions
peuvent exister
sans leur personnalité
principale.
Elles peuvent exister
qu'avec leurs livres
sacrés,
mais il n'y a pas
de christianisme
sans Christ
et donc
par rapport
à la foi chrétienne,
Christ est capital
donc il faut étudier
les Christ
si on veut
comprendre
les christianismes
et par rapport
à la profession
individuelle des fois,
personne n'essaiera
sauvé
si leur compréhension
du Christ
n'est pas
une compréhension
précise
et biblique.
On a vu
la préoccupation
des Écritures
à défendre
une compréhension
du Christ
les médiateurs
qui soit précise.
C'est l'objectif
des Évangiles,
c'est l'objectif
du Nouveau Testament
et plusieurs passages
des Écritures
nous montrent
de manière très claire
que si nous avons
la moindre déviation
à propos
de la personne
et l'œuvre
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
nous ne pouvons pas
être sauvés.
Donc pour donner
un exemple très clair
si nous ne croyons pas
à la naissance virginale
du Fils des Dieux
il n'y a pas de salut.
Les saluts
dépend
du fait
que les Fils des Dieux
soient devenus
véritablement chers
pour ne pas avoir
la contamination
du péché
par exemple
et pour pouvoir
représenter
véritablement
l'être humain.
Et donc
si nous avons tort
donc il ne suffit pas
de croire tout simplement
dans une conception
large du Christ
flux du Christ
il faut croire
au Christ
selon la Bible
et l'écrit
il est très précis
et la doctrine
de l'incarnation
elle est une condition
pour qu'on ait
un vrai médiateur
entre Dieu
et l'homme.
Pour qu'on ait
un médiateur vrai
entre Dieu et l'homme
il faut que ces médiateurs
aient la nature divine
et la nature humaine
et la Bible
elle-même
nous présente
les mystères
de l'incarnation
comme les plus grands
de tous les mystères
qu'on puisse considérer.
Donc
en ayant considéré
cette pertinence générale
du thème
on a considéré
les raisons principales
et notamment
ce sont les raisons bibliques
et quelque part
la Bible
dans son intégralité
dans toutes ses parties
et dans son message
central
de l'ensemble
c'est comme si
Dieu lui-même
était en train
de nous dire
quels sont les sujets
les plus importants
étudiés pour l'humanité.
Si la Bible
est les livres
les plus importants
les messages
centrales des écritures
les plus recourants
des écritures
est Jésus-Christ
lui-même
et l'importance
que la Bible nous donne
pour être précise
à propos du Christ
en tant que médiateur.
Et donc
je ne viens pas
vers la Bible
tout simplement
pour trouver
des messages
réconfortants
pour mes défis
d'aujourd'hui.
Ça c'est un bonus
que nous pouvons trouver.
Mais la Bible
elle est préoccupée
avec notre problème
radical d'un côté
et notre bonheur
suprême
de l'autre côté.
Et la réponse
pour ces deux
grandes questions
sont trouvées
en Christ.
Notre problème
radical dépend
d'une délivrance
de l'enfer
de l'esclavage
de péché
du monde
et de ses mondes
échoués.
Et c'est seulement
si quelqu'un
qui me représente
en tant qu'être humain
reçoit
pleinement
cette punition
sur sa peau
que je peux être
délivré
de l'enfer.
Mais en même temps
mon suprême bonheur
c'est la réjouissance
de la relation
avec Dieu
la réconciliation
pour pouvoir
contempler
sa gloire
et satisfaire
mon âme
avec
cette adoration
suprême.
Et l'adoration
suprême
la révélation
des dieux
se trouve
dans l'incarnation
du Christ.
Et donc
dans l'Ancien Testament
nous avons considéré
que Christ
il est la main
pour toutes les promesses
et les prophéties
de l'Ancien Testament
et nous avons considéré
spécialement
la précision
de ces prophéties.
C'est comme si
on était en train
de recevoir
de la part des dieux
une biographie
par anticipation
fiable
par anticipation.
Mais on a considéré
aussi
plusieurs déclarations
du Nouveau Testament
qui nous présentent
l'importance
du Christ
comme les seigneurs
souverains
et suprêmes
en tant que créateurs
et en tant que rédempteurs
toutes les choses
il soutient
par sa parole
toutes les choses
subsistent
en lui
et en même temps
il est considéré
par la parole
des dieux
comme les juges
suprêmes
et il est
le seul médiateur
entre Dieu
et les hommes.
Donc toutes ces
déclarations
superlatives
des écritures
ont pour but
appelé
toute notre attention.
Il y a quelque chose
infiniment plus important
que moi
quand je viens vers la Bible
et c'est Christ
lui-même.
Et la fiabilité
et tous les lettres
du Nouveau Testament
elles sont préoccupées
avec
la fiabilité
de ses enregistrements
à propos de la vie
du Christ
du Messie
du médiateur
à propos des événements
principaux
la signification
de son incarnation
de sa vie
de sa mort
de sa résurrection
la fiabilité
du fait
qu'il a été
vraiment incarné
que sa naissance
était une naissance
virginale
sa résurrection
son ascension
et donc
les événements
les plus importants
de l'œuvre
du Christ
et de sa personne
ou son identité
sont là
comme enregistrement
fiable.
Et donc
tout ça pour dire
que
la Bible
sacrée
la sainte Bible
est une manière
des dieux
de nous dire
il n'y a pas
un sujet
plus important
qui est d'étudier
à propos du Christ
et c'est ce qu'on doit faire
pour plus mystérieux
qu'il soit
à certains aspects
pour plus
qu'il s'assure
de notre capacité
de comprendre
nous devons y aller
avec l'espoir
de trouver
l'assurance
de notre salut
et de trouver
la gloire
des dieux lui-même
révélés en Christ
et donc
enlever
les sandales
de nos pieds
et nous approcher
de celui
qui est
le seul médiateur
entre Dieu et l'homme
les juges
suprêmes
de l'humanité
et c'est lui
qui a les créateurs
qui soutient
toutes les choses
ensuite
ce qu'on doit faire
à partir de là
c'est de considérer
la doctrine
elle-même
donc de définir
cette doctrine
bibliquement
la doctrine
de l'incarnation
et cette doctrine
plus large
de l'incarnation
donc à nouveau
les thèmes plus larges
c'est la rédemption
cette rédemption
qui a besoin
d'un médiateur parfait
et pour connaître
ce médiateur parfait
on doit contempler
la précision biblique
qui nous explique
comment Dieu
a pu pourvoir
un médiateur parfait
ces grands miracles
les plus grands
de tous les mystères
Dieu s'est fait chair
donc c'est l'incarnation
et l'incarnation
va impliquer
notamment
cette autre doctrine
de la naissance virginale
que nous allons
considérer aujourd'hui
et donc
en commençant
par cette définition
de l'incarnation
nous allons
à nouveau
lire les deux paragraphes
de la confession
des fois
qui nous aident
à définir
la doctrine
ou les conclusions
qui nous tireront
à partir
de plusieurs passages
bibliques
donc
il a plus à Dieu
dans son dessein éternel
de choisir
et d'ordonner
les sœurs Jésus
son fils unique
selon l'alliance passée
entre deux
pour être les médiateurs
entre Dieu
et l'homme
ces médiateurs
vont donc accomplir
trois offices
prophètes
sacrificateurs
et rois
les chefs
et sauveurs
de l'église
et son église
l'héritier
des toutes choses
et les juges
du monde
à qui
il a
de toute éternité
donné en peuple
pour être
sa postérité
et pour être
en temps volu
racheté
appelé
justifié
sanctifié
et glorifié
par lui
donc
ce sont
les implications
les conséquences
ou l'application
personnelle
à chaque individu
chrétien
de cette œuvre
parfaite
qui Christ
accomplit
en tant que médiateur
donc là on va
s'approfondir
dans ces aspects
des conversions
appel efficace
justification
sanctification
etc
au fur et à mesure
où nous allons plus tard
étudier les ministères
du Saint-Esprit
pour appliquer la rédemption
donc ici c'est par anticipation
car on est déjà
en train d'établir
un survol
mais nous
nous allons rester
concentrés
sur cette notion
de celui
qui a été
désigné
selon le déceint
interneur
des dieux
et qui à un moment donné
va se concrétiser
comme les médiateurs
parfaits
donc c'est le deuxième
paragraphe
donc qui va reprendre
cette notion
d'incarnation
et le deuxième
paragraphe
il nous dit
les fils des dieux
donc attention
à la personne
et fils des dieux
la seconde personne
de la trinité
étant vrai
et éternel
Dieu
égal
et des mêmes substances
que les pères
ayant accompli
la plénitude
du temps
a pris sur lui
la nature humaine
avec toutes les propriétés
essentielles
et les infirmités
communes
de cette nature
mais sans péché
ayant été conçue
par la puissance
de son esprit
dans les sangs
de la Vierge Marie
de la substance
de celle-ci
ainsi
de nature entière
parfaite
et distincte
la divinité
et l'humanité
furent
inséparablement
jouantes
et une seule personne
sans conversion
sans composition
ni confusion
cette personne
est vrai Dieu
et vrai homme
et cependant
un seul Christ
et seul médiateur
entre Dieu
et l'homme
quelle est la tentation
pour nous
et pourquoi
tous ces mots
qui servent à protéger
la doctrine
la tentation pour nous
c'est
de nous donner
par satisfaits
avec une doctrine
si glorieuse
et mystérieuse
qui nous concerne
et n'est pas
nous plonger
dans les détails
ça nous prive
d'un niveau
d'assurance
infiniment supérieur
!
et d'un niveau
d'adoration
beaucoup plus élevé
mais ça nous met
aussi à risque
car nous ne pouvons
pas nous empêcher
d'imaginer les choses
c'est impossible
de lire la Bible
et de ne pas
raisonner
avec la parole
de Dieu
de ne pas nous voir
face
à des difficultés
donc on vient
de lire
avant la prière
ces passages
qui va nous décrire
l'explication
de l'ange
à propos
de la conception
virginale
de Marie
et donc
cette description
que celui
qui sera né d'elle
sera appelé
fils de Dieu
le sang
qui sera conçu
en elle
et donc
nous
ne pouvons pas
nous empêcher
si nous sommes
en train de lire
la Bible
d'avoir
des imaginations
ou chercher
à comprendre
ce que les textes
sont décrits
et quand on voit
des termes
qui nous disent
par exemple
sans conversion
sans composition
sans confusion
c'est car
quand nous
nous livrons
à nos propres pensées
on peut facilement
tomber
dans l'une
de ces hérésies
et des hérésies
qui sont très graves
donc si mon idée
par exemple
du Christ
c'est
parfois
il se revêtait
de la cape
du vêtement
des dieux
et parfois
de l'homme
et que ça donne
l'impression
pour moi
que c'était
plus ou moins
un mélange
des deux natures
je suis déjà
tombé dans l'hérésie
avec des grandes
implications
pour les saluts
pour la rédemption
si je pense
par exemple
à la trinité
comme tout simplement
des manifestations
différentes
d'une seule personne
je suis dans
une hérésie aussi
de laquelle
dépend mon salut
aussi
et donc nous
nous pouvons être
très naïfs
mais notre obligation
biblique
c'est d'aller
jusqu'à où
la bible
nous révèle
avec clarté
et le plus
on avance
avec la considération
biblique
en reconnaissant
nos limitations
mais en restant
accroché
à la révélation
biblique
les plus on est
assuré
de notre salut
et les plus
on est protégé
des hérésies
et les plus glorieux
Christ ressort
à nos yeux
et donc
je vais vous présenter
par exemple
de quelle manière
nous définissons
ou nous comprenons
cette définition
de notre confession
des fois
de cette doctrine
de cette vérité
biblique
de l'incarnation
donc la première chose
qu'il faut reconnaître
par les langages
ici utilisés
c'est que nous sommes
devant
les plus grands
de tous les mystères
donc
les fils de Dieu
la seconde personne
de la Trinité
est un vrai
et éternel Dieu
égal
et de la même substance
du Père
qui nous montre
une partie
de cette vérité
et qui ensuite
va nous dire
par exemple
qu'il a été conçu
par la puissance
du Saint-Esprit
dans les sangs
de la Vierge Marie
dès la substance
de celle-ci
il a
la même substance
de Dieu
de laquelle
il ne va plus jamais
se détacher
c'est impossible
sinon il laisse
être Dieu
mais il a quand même
pris la substance
de Marie
pour être
véritablement incarné
et pour plus
qu'on soit obligé
de l'affirmer
clairement
nous sommes également
obligés
de ne pas suggérer
!
que ces deux substances
soient mélangées
on n'est pas devant
une espèce
de composition
accrochée
il y a une question
inséparable
d'harmonie
et la Bible
elle nous dit
de manière très claire
et la parole
a été faite
chère
et elle a habité
parmi nous
et la parole ici
c'est logos
et sans contredit
les mystères
de la piété
est grand
Dieu a été manifesté
en chair
justifié par l'esprit
vu des anges
prêchés parmi la nation
crus dans les mondes
élevés dans la gloire
les mystères
de la piété
est grand
les mystères singuliers
les plus grands
de tous les mystères
et donc
quand on parle
de l'incarnation
nous sommes en train
de parler
de l'entrée
des dieux
dans l'histoire
pour accomplir
les saluts
et c'est l'entrée
des dieux
véritables
par la personne
des dieux
les fils
l'incarnation
donc
vise
affirmer
quelles sont
les affirmations
qu'on doit faire
et admirer
et apprécier
c'est que
les fils éternels
des dieux
appris une véritable
nature humaine
la naissance
de Jésus
n'est pas
les commencements
d'une nouvelle personne
celui qui était né
à Bethlehem
elle est même
fils éternel
des dieux lui-même
et donc
quand on voit
les bébés
dans les mangeoires
on n'est pas
en train de voir
la naissance
d'une nouvelle
personne
et pour plus
qui est dans sa
nature humaine
il a dû se développer
avec un dieu
qui s'est déplié
de sa gloire
pour accomplir
l'objectif
de salut
la nature divine
voilée
quelque part
surtout
pendant certaines
périodes
de sa vie
n'annulait pas
la réalité
de cette même nature
car les bébés
dans les mangeoires
la personne
qui était
dans ses corps
est la même personne
qui soutenait
tout l'univers
par sa parole puissante
tous les cosmos
étaient soutenus
par celui
qui apparemment
était fragile
dans ses mangeoires
avec une mère
qui n'avait pas
où accoucher
cette mère
qui accouche
Jésus
dans ses mangeoires
était elle-même
soutenue
par la puissance
de ses bébés
qui étaient
les crises lui-même
Dieu les fils
lui-même
les fils éternels
des dieux
donc c'est pas
tout simplement
les dieux créateurs
qui rentrent
dans son monde
dans sa création
mais c'est aussi
l'éternel
les préexistants
au commencement
la parole
était Dieu
elle était avec Dieu
et donc
la préexistence
éternelle
du fils
va permettre
qu'il rentre
dans les temps
et qu'il soit
dans sa nature humaine
il soit affecté
par les temps
donc la seconde
personne de la trinité
assume l'humanité
sans cesser
d'être Dieu
et donc
le roman
8-3 nous dit
que Dieu a envoyé
envoyé son fils
dans une chair
semblable à celle du péché
donc il a été
envoyé
depuis l'éternité
Dieu envoie son propre fils
et donc
à Bethléry
on est en train de contempler
l'entrée
dans l'histoire
temporelle
du fils éternel
et ce n'est pas
le commencement
de son existence
ok
et donc
comme le premier paragraphe
nous dit
le Seigneur Jésus
son fils unique
et le deuxième paragraphe
nous dit
le fils de Dieu
la seconde personne
de la trinité
nous devons
faire écho
et comprendre
l'importance
de ces déclarations
car nous voyons
que l'incarnation
elle est au centre
des écritures
elle est annoncée
en Malachie 4-2
mais pour vous
qui craignez
mon nom
s'élèvera
les soleils
de la justice
et la guérison
sera sur ses ailes
et Philippian
qui nous dit
qui existe
en forme de Dieu
il n'a point regardé
comme une proie arrachée
d'être égal à Dieu
mais il s'est déplué
lui-même
en prenant une forme
des serviteurs
en dévenant
semblable aux hommes
et ayant paru
comme un simple homme
il s'est humilié
lui-même
s'érendant
obéissant
jusqu'à la mort
même jusqu'à la mort
des croix
donc toutes
l'économie
de l'alliance
va converger
à la venue du Christ
l'histoire
est gouvernée
jusqu'à ce que
l'incarnation
soit considérée
comme l'événement
le plus important
de l'histoire
et un événement
qui se passe
dans la plénitude
des temps
et là
nous devons avancer
pour être encore
plus précis
dans nos déclarations
quelles sont
les affirmations
qu'on doit faire
à propos de l'incarnation
pour préserver
sa gloire
son mystère
et pour nous protéger
des hérésies
donc la première
c'est de nous rappeler
que l'incarnation
elle
redouble
ou renforce
l'importance
suprême
de la doctrine
de la Trinité
on ne doit jamais jouer
avec la doctrine
de la Trinité
car
notre salut
dépend
de la réalité
telle qu'elle est
l'existence du cosmos
telle qu'il est
comme Schaeffer
par exemple
va défendre
même de manière
philosophique
les besoins
de la Trinité
car nous vivons
dans un univers
qui réjouit
des variétés
en même temps
qui réjouit
d'unité
et donc
l'unité
si elle est
tout simplement
l'unicité
ou l'uniformité
ne permet pas
des variations
Dieu ne pourrait
même pas être
amour
comme la Bible
nous le présente
s'il n'y a pas
d'éternité
dans l'amour
et pour que l'amour
soit éternel
plusieurs personnes
doivent exister
en même temps
et donc
Dieu peut être
appelé
amour
car depuis
toute l'éternité
Dieu a
subsisté
en trois personnes
mais surtout
quand on pense
à la rédemption
ça serait impossible
que Dieu
puisse développer
la rédemption
pour une race
des créatures
qui se rébellent
contre lui
sans que
l'une des personnes
dans la sainte trinité
puisse être
si condescendant
de devenir
homme
et nous représenter
en même temps
que
Dieu les pères
devrait garder
sa position
en tant que juge
donc nous avons
besoin d'un médiateur
nous avons besoin
d'un juge
et nous voyons
l'importance
de la doctrine
de la trinité
car nous avions
besoin
d'un médiateur
qui développe
son rôle
sans qu'il ait
pères
perd sa place
en tant que
juge
et gouverneur
et donc
la trinité
elle est nécessaire
car la personne
explicitement
affirmée
dans la bible
c'est la seule
personne
qui est affirmée
dans la bible
comme notre médiateur
le saint esprit
ne nous est pas
présenté dans la bible
comme les médiateurs
responsables
pour notre rédemption
Dieu les pères
ne nous est pas
présenté dans la bible
comme les responsables
pour notre rédemption
ou pour la médiation
celui qui est
responsable
pour être notre
représentant
notre médiateur
c'est Dieu
les fils
et la bible
les déclare
de manière
explicite
donc sans trinité
il n'y a pas
de rédemption
de réconciliation
avec Dieu
car l'incarnation
n'est pas possible
si le saint esprit
n'est pas en train
d'opérer
dans les ventres
de Marie
si Dieu les fils
n'est pas en train
de venir
devenir un homme
comme nous
et si Dieu les pères
n'est pas en train
d'envoyer
et de garder sa position
en tant que juge
dans cette affaire
et donc
notre déclaration
qu'on doit faire
et connaître
c'est que
la doctrine
de l'incarnation
n'affirme pas
que les dieux trinitaires
s'est fait chair
mais c'est la douzième
personne de la trinité
qui s'est fait chair
c'est le Seigneur Jésus
lui-même
Jean
chapitre 1
verset 1
au commencement
était la parole
la parole était avec Dieu
et la parole
était Dieu
a été faite chair
et elle habitait parmi nous
pleine des grâces
et des vérités
et nous avons contemplé
sa gloire
une gloire
attention à la définition
comme la gloire
du fils unique
venu du Père
Galate 4
mais lorsqu'il est temps
a été accompli
Dieu a envoyé
son fils
né d'une femme
et né sous la loi
donc toute perspective
du Christ
comme celle des musulmans
comme Christ
un grand prophète
etc
mais pas vraiment Dieu
ne peut pas passer
aucune hérésie modaliste
car les hérésies modalistes
vont dire que ce sont
des manifestations
différentes des dieux
et là nous sommes
devant des déclarations
bibliques très claires
qui nous montrent
que Dieu a envoyé
son fils
pour être né d'une femme
et être né sous la loi
!
Romain 8
car chose impossible
à la loi
parce que la chair
la rendait sans force
Dieu a condamné
les péchés
dans la chair
en envoyant
à cause du péché
son propre fils
dans une chair
semblable
à celle du péché
donc ici c'est très important
car les semblables
à celle du péché
les semblables
s'appliquent
pour protéger
l'idée
que cette chair
véritable
soit contaminée
par les péchés
mais la chair
qui est décrite ici
c'est une chair littérale
ce n'est pas une apparence
des chairs
c'est une chair
littérale
une chair humaine
et c'est intéressant
c'était à cause du péché
que Christ a été envoyé
ou que les fils
a été envoyés
dans la chair
pourquoi?
pour renforcer
la totale incapacité
de la race humaine
contaminée par les péchés
de trouver entre nous
un qui pourrait
vivre une vie parfaite
donc à cause du péché
le Seigneur Jésus
a dû prendre
la chair humaine
pour accomplir
la loi
à notre place
et pour pouvoir
être condamné
à notre place
à cause de notre péché
dans une chair humaine
et donc c'est important
pour nous
le plus qu'on puisse
garder la précision
biblique
car
nous pouvons avoir
des chants
et nous pouvons même
faire des déclarations
quand on prêche
qui parfois
sont bien encadrées
mais parfois
manquent et ratent
avec la précision
donc il faut savoir
respecter
les contextes historiques
les contextes bibliques
ou même les contextes
d'une prédication
car parfois
on peut dire
tout simplement
de manière très générale
Jésus
et Dieu fait chair
c'est vrai
mais il faut qu'on ait
la précision biblique
Dieu les fils
fait chair
ou la deuxième personne
de la trinité
fait chair
donc ça
c'est l'une des confusions
que mes enfants
ils ont aussi
pour comprendre
les choses
car à plusieurs reprises
on se demande
on les demande
qui est mort
à la croix
ils vont dire
Dieu
et dans un certain sens
c'est correct
mais là
on voit clairement
qu'ils sont en train
de faire les mélanges
entre Dieu
les papas du ciel
et Dieu les fils
et c'est important
de les apprendre
de leur apprendre
le plus tôt possible
l'importance
de ces précisions
par exemple
même dans
les conciles d'Éphèse
ou les symboles d'Éphèse
les crédeaux
il a cette déclaration
Marie
qu'est-ce qui vient après ?
Mère de Dieu
Théotokos
et donc bien sûr
ça a provoqué aussi
pas mal
des débats
et des conflits
mais c'était
une réaction
intentionnelle
à la suggestion
que Christ
il était
assisté par Dieu
ou une apparence
des dieux
mais qu'il n'était pas
vraiment
les fils des dieux
qu'il n'avait pas
la nature divine
l'hérésie du moment
et donc pour renforcer
la déclaration
du crédeau
on a fait
ces rajuts
mère des dieux
et là
si on comprend très bien
le contexte
on voit l'importance
d'avoir fait
cette emphase
mais nous devons
quand même
faire attention
et avoir
la précision nécessaire
pour savoir
que Marie
mère des dieux
plus tard
serait utilisée
par l'emphase catholique
pour donner
quelque part
plus d'importance
à Marie
que Jésus lui-même
parfois
ou au moins
pour exagérer
beaucoup
l'importance
de Marie
sur la base
de cette déclaration
et donc
c'est pas que
l'intention
ou ce qui
veut être
communiqué
par les symboles
soit incorrect
car Christ
est Dieu
Jésus
fils des dieux
est Dieu
mais
c'est important
de nous rappeler
Marie
elle est plutôt
responsable
pour contribuer
avec la nature
humaine
du Seigneur Jésus
et pas
avec la nature
divine
du Seigneur Jésus
ok
donc faire attention
à la précision
chercher la précision
et la spécificité
comme la Bible
l'est fait aussi
une troisième déclaration
c'est que l'incarnation
n'était pas qu'une apparence
ou une forme
assumée
et donc là
on voit de manière
très claire
dans la confession
qui va mettre
toute cette emphase
sur la personne
du fils des dieux
qui a pris sur lui
la nature humaine
et donc là
c'est pour nous protéger
surtout
et donc plus tard aussi
conçu par la présence
du Saint-Esprit
dans les sens
de la Vierge Marie
de la substance
de celle-ci
pour mettre l'emphase
que la substance
de sa nature humaine
était une substance
véritablement humaine
ok
et donc
les mêmes propriétés
essentielles
etc
donc c'était pas
une apparence
d'un être humain
comme un fantôme
qui donne une impression
théophonique
d'être un être humain
lorsqu'il n'était pas
mais il y a
cette hérésie
qui était combattue
qui était
vraiment
liée
à ce qu'on appelait
les docétismes
cette division
entre
corps et esprit
et les corps
la matière
était plutôt
d'une importance
inférieure
ou plutôt
corrompue
et on ne pourrait
pas imaginer
en fait
que Dieu
lui-même
aurait pu
s'y mélanger
ou s'approcher
citant
de la nature humaine
et donc
cette hérésie
elle a été combattue
déjà dans le Nouveau Testament
donc personne
les personnes
qui nient
que Christ
est venu en chair
c'est l'esprit
de l'antichrist
lui-même
ok
et la réalité
c'est pour
nous protéger
de cette hérésie
donc selon eux
la matière
était mauvaise
Christ ne pouvait pas
avoir un vrai corps
ou mort
et le problème
c'est que
sans incarnation
véritable
voilà pourquoi
nous dépendons
de protéger
cette doctrine
car sans
une nature humaine
véritable
il ne peut pas
être un vrai
représentant
de la nature humaine
car nous
par exemple
tous les êtres humains
impénitents
qui sont morts
sans la foi
en Jésus Christ
et qui
sont envoyés
déjà
ok
à l'enfer
ils ne sont pas
encore
en train de subir
la punition
juste
qu'ils méritent
souffrir
car leur punition
doit être
une punition
éternelle
mais
avec la capacité
de souffrir
à la mesure exacte
de leur rébellion
contre Dieu
donc
les âmes
de ceux qui partent
au paradis
des sangs
ne sont pas non plus
en train de réjouir
du paradis
avec leur plan potentiel
voilà pourquoi
la Bible
elle nous parle
du jugement final
et après
le jugement final
ou dans l'occasion
du jugement final
on aura
cette résurrection
et c'est une résurrection
des corps
qui ont été
morts
en corruption
et
les sangs
qui auront encore
glorifié
pour aller au paradis
réjouir de la plénitude
et la gloire future
et les impénitents
qui vont avoir
encore aussi
transformé
et qui auront
la capacité
de supporter
la mesure
des souffrances
qui est convenable
à la rébellion
contre Dieu
et s'il y a
la moindre possibilité
pour nous
d'être délivrés
d'une éternité
des souffrances
dans l'intensité
qu'il faut
il faut
nécessairement
que le Seigneur
Jésus Christ
ait souffert
dans un corps
humain
littéral
la condensation
avec toute l'intensité
de la punition
qui devrait
retomber sur nous
et donc
quand on considère
la possibilité
d'être délivré
de l'enfer
de manière juste
nous avons besoin
de quelqu'un
qui puisse porter
la nature humaine
et supporter
l'intensité
de cette juste
punition
qu'on méritait
vous comprenez
et si Christ
n'est pas ressuscité
comme premier né
d'une nouvelle humanité
d'une nouvelle création
nous n'avons pas
non plus l'espoir
de pouvoir ressusciter
avec un corps
similaire
et semblable
au sien
lui-même
qui a offert son corps
pour être touché
par Thomas
pour constater
que pour plus
que ces corps
soient glorieux
et nouveaux
il reste quand même
un corps humain
glorifié
et donc
sans
l'incarnation
réelle
il n'y a pas
de salut
pour nous
et la parole
a été faite
Jean 1.14
chair
et elle a habité
parmi nous
Jean
dans sa première lettre
tout esprit
qui confesse
Jésus-Christ
venu en chair
est des dieux
et celui qui nie
est l'antichrist
Luc 24
et 39
il dit à Thomas
touché
et voyez
un esprit
n'a ni chair
ni eau
comme vous voyez
que j'ai
ok
une autre déclaration
qu'on doit faire
c'est que les fils
des dieux
la seconde personne
de la trinité
est un vrai dieu
pardon
c'est que la doctrine
de l'incarnation
affirme
que la deuxième
personne éternelle
de la trinité
elle-même
est celui
qui a assumé
cette nature humaine
sans devenir
une nouvelle personne
ou être
la composition
des deux personnes
donc il n'y a pas eu
voilà
c'est un mystère
pour nous
et chaque étape
sera un mystère
mais par exemple
lorsque
un enfant
est né
c'est un mystère
pour nous
de nous demander
la formation
de son âme
ou de sa personnalité
ok
donc on sait
qu'il y a des choses
qui vont prendre des papas
des choses qui vont prendre
des mamans
on sait que
la chair
a une composition
mélangée
quelque part
composée
mais c'est une seule chose
par contre
les miracles
que le Saint-Esprit
a opéré
dans la naissance virginale
a fait
qu'il a pu
recevoir
un corps légitime
mais que la personne
qui a habité
dans ses corps
était la personne
du Saint-Jésus
et donc
voilà pourquoi
on a besoin
d'avoir
des déclarations
bibliques
si claires
et si précises
pour nous dire
que celui
qui a été
engendré
en Marie
était
le fils
des dieux
éternel
la parole
qui a été faite hier
on n'a aucune mention
aucune suggestion
au contraire
qu'on puisse avoir
une personnalité
en Jésus-Christ
qui soit née
de l'être humain
sa personne
était la personne
divine
et donc
on ne sait pas
jusqu'à où ça va
cette notion
de la psyché
ou cette interaction
entre l'âme
et la personnalité
ou la personne
ou les notions
physiologiques
ou comment les émotions
s'éjouent
on ne connaît pas
dans quel niveau
d'interaction
ces choses
vont s'éjouer
dans cette personne
ou dans cette nature
ou double nature
du Christ
mais nous devons
affirmer
avec toute précision
que la personne
qui habitait
cette nature humaine
qui a une âme
était la personne
du Christ
elle-même
donc
l'hérésie
qui on vise
combattre
quand on fait
cette déclaration
c'est le nestorianisme
qui suggère
une séparation
trop forte
entre les deux
natures du Christ
conduisant
à concevoir
Jésus
comme
en étant
presque deux
personnes morales
les fils des dieux
qui allaient
jouer
une influence
sur la personne
humaine
du Christ
et bien sûr
qu'on aura
des moments
des tensions
où nous allons
voir comment
la nature humaine
du Christ
était tellement légitime
qu'il va chercher
même
à manifester
un désir
immédiat
à éviter
la croix
mais bien sûr
que
sa conviction
par rapport
à sa mission
va prévaloir
va surmonter
et c'est pas
une bipolarité
évidente
ni une schizophrénie
et encore moins
deux personnes
qui sont en train
de se battre
c'est tout simplement
une évidence
concrète
et réelle
du fait
qu'il a vraiment
assumé
la nature humaine
et qu'il devrait
faire face
à la punition
de l'enfer
à la croix
et qu'il avance
pour le faire
et donc
si nous n'avons pas
une seule personne
nous n'avons pas
une personne
qui ne soit pas
contaminée
et nous n'avons pas
un seul médiateur
nous avons
dans la personne
du Christ
et si nous avons
deux personnes
nous n'avons pas
un médiateur
il faut que
cette personne
ou que ces médiateurs
soient la personne
elle-même
qui vit la vie
parfaite
à notre place
et qui soit
mort à la croix
à notre place
si nous créditons
un Jésus
ou un fils
des dieux
qui n'était pas
vraiment humain
les aspects positifs
de son accomplissement
mais
la personne
elle-même
qui nous représente
en tant qu'être humain
n'est pas celle
qui accomplit
l'obéissance parfaite
ou qui soit mort
à la croix
pour nous
cette personne
sous l'influence
des dieux
mais qui elle-même
n'est pas la personne
qui est en train
d'accomplir
elle ne peut pas
nous représenter
véritablement
vous comprenez
et donc c'est
très important pour nous
que ce soit
une seule personne
qui accomplit
cette oeuvre
donc
plus ou moins
les mêmes versets
qui soit
née d'une femme
née sous la loi
que ce soit
la même personne
les fils des dieux
envoyés
philippiens
en existant
en forme des dieux
donc à chaque fois
la Bible attribue
à la personne du Christ
et il n'y a pas
de mélange
des compositions
à cet égard
la doctrine
de l'incarnation
implique aussi
qu'il n'a pas eu
aucun changement
dans la personne
du fils des dieux
donc il reste
éternellement
la même personne
divine
avant
pendant
et après
l'incarnation
voilà quoi
il va dire
clairement
perdant
t'aimant
j'ai livré mon esprit
à l'annonce
l'énonciation
de sa naissance
virginale
c'est dit
que son fils
est rappelé
les fils de très haut
donc
on voit de manière
très claire
par tous les passages
bibliques
que
même si
la deuxième personne
de la Trinité
a ajouté
dans cette interaction
glorieuse
autour du trône céleste
les corps humains
glorifiés
il ne va plus jamais
se dissocier
de ses corps
il n'est pas
en tant que personne
divine
limité à ses corps
c'est clair pour vous ?
et donc
la deuxième personne
de la Trinité
a porté
ses corps
au ciel
mais
elle n'est pas
limitée
en tant que Dieu
à ses corps
et donc
ça n'a pas affecté
dans aucun cas
la subsistance
de la deuxième personne
de la Trinité
dans
la Sainte Trinité
il reste Dieu
de la même subsistance
de Dieu
avant
pendant
et après
l'incarnation
et donc
l'hérésie
à nouveau
qui on vise à opposer
quand on affirme
qu'il n'y a jamais eu
des transformations
explicites
ou limitées
ou quelque chose
qui aurait pu affecter
la nature du Christ
ou de la personne
du Seigneur Jésus
la personne
du Fils des dieux
c'est les modalismes
qui vont suggérer
qu'il n'y a pas
des distinctions
personnelles
réelles
dans la Trinité
et
parfois
Dieu se manifeste
en tant que Père
parfois en tant que Fils
parfois en tant que Saint-Esprit
et donc
on serait plutôt
devant des modes
ou des manifestations
successives
des dieux
mais pas forcément
en train de considérer
la personne
du Fils
du Père
et du Saint-Esprit
de manière distincte
et donc
si la personne
des dieux
dans Dieu
qui n'a pas
qui ne subsiste pas
entre personnes
c'est simplement
simplement manifesté
en tant que homme
cela va effacer
la nature humaine
réelle
qu'il devrait voir
pour nous représenter
les modalismes
ne peuvent pas
nous représenter
car si c'est juste
une apparence humaine
et
ça efface aussi
les interactions
dans l'économie
de la rédemption
les rôles du Père
en tant que juge
et donc
si on n'a pas
des distinctions
personnelles
au-dedans
de la Trinité
la possibilité
de la rédemption
n'est pas réelle
et l'incarnation
non plus
et la Bible
elle dit clairement
les distinctions
sont claires
bon la parole
était envoyée
était les fils
des dieux
etc
on voit plusieurs passages
avec les distinctions
très claires
et donc
la doctrine
de l'incarnation
ne signifie pas
qu'un changement
s'est produit
dans la personne
du fils des dieux
il y a un changement
des conditions
d'apparition
et des manifestations
mais non
un changement
de la personne
du fils des dieux
il a les mêmes fils
éternels
dans les saints
des maris
dans la crèche
et dans toute
son existence
humaine
et donc
nous ne pouvons
jamais dire
que le fils des dieux
a été transformé
en homme
car cela
impliquerait
une altération
dans la personne
éternelle
l'expression
Dieu
devenu
homme
parfois peut-être
trompeuse
et nous devons chercher
la précision
à cet égard
aussi
car cela peut suggérer
!
quand on parle
dévenu
cela peut changer
l'être
l'ontologie
si vous voulez
du fils des dieux
et donc la bible
elle est très claire
mais certaines traductions
s'apprêtent à la confusion
c'est prête à la confusion
par exemple
Jean 14
et la parole
a été
faite
chair
donc ça peut porter
la confusion
car l'essence
correct
c'est
il s'est fait
pour soi
chair
ou
il s'est revêtu
de chair
comme s'il avait fait
pour soi
une chair
plutôt
que
de laisser
d'être dieu
et s'est transformé
en chair humaine
vous comprenez?
donc
il s'est fait chair
il s'est préparé
encore pour lui
roman 8.3
il a envoyé
son propre fils
dans une chair
semblable
à celle du péché
donc
les mêmes fils
il vient
dans la condition humaine
mais c'est
les mêmes fils
des dieux
qui est en train
de venir
dans une autre condition
ok
et donc
Dieu
a envoyé
son fils
donc c'est comme si
il était en train
de prendre
ce type de véhicule
si vous voulez
pour se manifester
pour se transporter
pour arriver
à accomplir
ce qu'il a
accompli
et en même temps
on doit être
précis
et avoir
les soins
de ne pas vouloir
suggérer
que cette interaction
du Christ
avec son corps
soit quelque chose
de détaché
même tout simplement
véhicule
ce n'est pas le cas
c'était une vraie nature humaine
donc Jésus Christ
est venu en chair
avec une continuité
personnelle
de la personne
et donc
c'est
les mêmes
éternels
Dieu les fils
qui est venu
encore
deux autres insistances
donc
pas seulement
une apparence humaine
donc on a déjà
parlé sur ça
mais
l'hérésie combattue
et les docétismes
à nouveau
c'est le gnosticisme
primitif
qui veut suggérer
qu'il avait
l'apparence d'un corps
une forme humaine
illusoire
sans véritable
humanité réelle
et donc Christ
il ne se montre pas
comme un homme
il
devient quelque part
réellement
homme
donc Hébreu 2
il a lui-même
également participé
de la même nature
de la même chair
et sang
donc Hébreu
il va exprimer
de manière littérale
les chairs
la chair
et les sang
Jésus Christ
est venu en chair
la parole a été faite
chair
donc pour
renforcer cette conviction
et
il a pris
une pleine
nature humaine
une nature humaine
qu'il a pris
des maris
et donc
il a dû être
rendu semblable
en toutes choses
à ses frères
Hébreu 2
prenant une forme
des serviteurs
tenté comme nous
en toutes choses
sans commettre péché
semblable
à la chair humaine
toutefois
sans péché
et nous voyons
de manière très claire
que cette nature humaine
il a pris
des maris
et voilà pourquoi
nous devons insister
sur l'importance
de la naissance
sur la conception virginale
avec toutes les propriétés
essentielles
et les infirmités
communes de cette nature
mais sans péché
ayant été conçue
par la puissance
de son esprit
dans les sangs
de la Vierge Marie
et de la substance
de celle-ci
et donc
quand on affirme
que la nature
du Christ
était humaine
était vraie
était réelle
nous savons très bien
par la description
du passage
que nous avons lu
que cette nature humaine
elle a été
conçue
formée
par les saints esprits
dans les ventres
des maris
en faisant usage
du matériel
biologique
des maris
donc ça va apporter
pour nous
des questions
pour lesquelles
on n'a pas
de réponse absolue
mais nous pouvons
conjecturer
qui
Adam étant
les représentants
de la race humaine
la circoncision
nous donnant
la piste
en fait
que nous sommes
en train de nous rappeler
qui est la transmission
du péché
de la coupabilité
vient par représentation
donc touche
toute la race
mais la transmission
de la corruption
du péché
vient de manière
biologique
comme on a déjà
considéré ensemble
quand on a étudié
sur les péchés
et que cette
connexion directe
la contribution
de l'homme
dans la relation
n'a pas eu lieu
pour les cas de Marie
donc on n'a pas
de réponse absolue
je ne veux pas être
défini à cet égard
mais cet aspect mystérieux
il est très important
pour nous de reconnaître
en tout cas
ce qui est clair
et que nous devons affirmer
c'est que
les nouvelles Adam
ne viendra pas
de la lignée directe
d'Adam
c'est comme si
Dieu était en train
de couper
la continuité
de cette connexion
et qu'ils doivent
participer
de la nature humaine
concrète
réelle
car Marie
elle
oui
elle vient de la nature
d'Adam
mais
la génération
voilà
la formation
du corps du Christ
à partir de la
substance de Marie
a été sous
les miracles
de la superintendance
du Saint-Esprit
pour que ces corps
ne soient pas contaminés
par les péchés
et c'est possible
que cette non-contamination
soit due au fait
qu'il n'y a pas eu
une communication
humaine
de la part de l'homme
à cet égard
donc ça c'est un mystère
c'est une conjecture
je ne suis pas en train
d'affirmer ça
avec certitude
mais la certitude
qu'on doit avoir
c'est que Christ
il vient de la lignée
humaine
mais sans
participer
de cette liaison
directe
à la sémence
d'Adam
et donc c'est
cette sémence
engendrée par
les Saint-Esprits
mais
ce que nous devons
affirmer clairement
c'est que la nature
humaine du Christ
a été formée
à partir de la nature
réelle
des maris
être humains
ok
et donc voilà
on ne peut pas
aller au-delà
de cette déclaration
mais nous ne pouvons
jamais être
en dessous
de cette déclaration
et donc
tout cela
toutes ces déclarations
qu'on a considérées
ensemble
c'est pour nous rappeler
que nous devons
rester accrochés
à la révélation biblique
et à la précision biblique
sachant
que la moindre déviation
va enlever
complètement
nous ne pouvons pas
dire par exemple
que
les Saint-Esprits
au ventre de Marie
il a formé
à partir de rien
une nouvelle nature humaine
sinon
cela ne pouvait pas
représenter notre race
non plus
ok
et Dieu avait promis
que ça serait
de la descendance
de la femme
ok
et donc il faut
naturellement
que cette nature humaine
soit une nature humaine
réelle
ok
et donc on voit
comment
chacune de ces déclarations
la moindre déviation
va compromettre
les saluts
et les prochains mystères
qu'on va considérer
la semaine prochaine
c'est de rentrer
de manière plus objective
à la considération
de la naissance virginale
et de la double nature
du Seigneur Jésus
les évidences
pour sa nature humaine
pour sa nature divine
et la conception virginale
avec
une considération
plus biblique
à cet égard
ok
donc voilà
on doit garder
les mystères
et contempler
et apprécier
la gloire
et les implications
pour notre rédemption
à cet égard
et les choses